Republicans are increasingly demanding
suggesting that Ron DeSantis block the
extradition of Donald Trump from Florida
to New York if indeed Donald Trump is
indicted and arrested in the state of
New York as many of us believe he might
be I guess although it was supposed to
happen Tuesday and then Wednesday and
then it didn't happen put that aside for
a moment more and more Republicans are
making the request that DeSantis block
the extradition of trump to New York can
DeSantis even do this well that's a good
question we'll get to that in a moment
first here is Florida Republican
Congressman Matt Gates making the case
if I were governor of Florida I would
not allow any Floridian to be hauled
before some soros-backed prosecutor in
some blue City over politics and I
wouldn't make an exception to not
protect the president of the United
States Ron DeSantis should be standing
in the breach to stop any sort of
extradition of President Trump from the
state of Florida and the fact that he's
not doing so puts every Floridian at
risk who could be the subject of a false
allegation I know Ron desantiswell he's
a friend but he hasn't been the target
of false and persistent allegations like
President Trump has and so I don't think
he really understands the nature of this
fight right now I think that it was a
bit uncouth for him to take a jab at the
former president and there's a role for
the governor of Florida here I think to
stand up for our state for the rule of
law and to push back against the
sorosization of the criminal justice
system so is it actually something that
Ron DeSantis can do I will tell you in a
moment Charlie Kirk making the exact
same case about this extradition and
everybody is on message with the Soros
stuff you will notice why doesn't Ron
DeSantis create a sanctuary state for a
former president under political
persecution
if the left is able to create Sanctuary
States for rapists and murderers Thugs
and criminals
I don't think it's too big of an ass for
Ron DeSantis critic to create a
sanctuary state for a former president
who's being persecuted
by a Soros funded D.A yeah so it's an
interesting legal question can a
governor block the extradition of an
indicted person from their state to the
state in which they are indicted can a
governor do that Governors do have the
power to block extradition of a person
who is wanted in another state but in
very limited circumstances a governor
May block the extradition of a person if
the governor determines that the
person's rights would be violated in the
extradition or if the governor believes
that the request for extradition is
politically motivated or improper now
that just happens to be
exactly what these right Wingers are
claiming they are saying that the the
prosecution of trump if it happens
is politically motivated would be
politically motivated however it is not
that the governor just says yep it's
politically motivated so there's no
extradition if a governor asserts that
they are blocking extradition from their
state to another for that reason it can
be challenged in court and ultimately
it's up to courts to determine whether
extraditions should be allowed
from everything I've read right now
there is every indication that if
DeSantis tried to block Trump's
extradition from Florida to New York on
these grounds courts would say you can't
do it
also worth noting Governors cannot block
extradition to another country that
falls under Federal jurisdiction so it's
a nice little pipe dream that Charlie
Kirk and Matt Gates have but it is very
unlikely to be what keeps Trump out of
the state of New York and by the way
Trump's lawyers have already said he
would surrender will it happen uh will
the arrest happen that's a different
question one of our sponsors today is
Leisure of NYC offering Ultra
comfortable fair trade men's clothing at
fair prices guys know it can be very
tough to find good boxers and t-shirts
the search is over because all boxer
briefs by Leisure of NYC are made with
amazingly soft moisture wicking viscose
from bamboo super lightweight like air
but it doesn't Bunch up and it's also
great for the planet Leisure of NYC also
makes really great supima cotton crew
neck t-shirts less than one percent of
men's Basics today are made with supima
cotton it is the best out there it feels
like Silk quite frankly you can walk
around in a scratchy t-shirt all day or
you can enjoy the cloud soft feel of
supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair trade and made sustainably go pick
up the most comfortable t-shirts and
boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below